hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
one vitally important topic that Cicero
is going to discuss in book 1 of on
duties has to do with the the
intersection between justice and
punishment or or indeed revenge or
retribution and this is a place where
not only is justice needed but justice
has to come in and modify another of the
virtues which is courage fortitude Oh or
great spiritedness without justice
courage becomes something non virtuous
and even vicious so this is a very
important discussion and it has some
important implications as well for how
we deal with the common experience of
being wronged by other people and you
know administering discipline and how we
in fact deal with this sort of thing on
a societal level when people say commit
crimes or or offend against others in in
different ways so one of the key ideas
that we see here is that justice has to
govern punishment or retribution or
revenge or what you've got there is if
justice is not doing that it's going to
become unjust and it's going to become
vicious and it's not going to serve its
purpose remember what is the the point
of justice we are social creatures and
justice is the virtue that that's
required for us rational creatures to be
able to live together in some sort of
harmony now there are going to be cases
where people do the wrong thing and
attack each other and salt each other
damage each other you know cut each
other off you know affect each other in
a variety of ways so Cicero wants to
stress to us that we actually have moral
duties he uses the word which is you
know the whole title of the book he says
we have oficio
we have duties we have off
we have moral obligations even towards
those who have done us wrong he says
those from whom we receive some sort of
in urea an insult and injury some sort
of harm this is a very important idea
they don't cease to be human
they don't cease to be our neighbors our
friends our classmates whatever whatever
it is that we want to say just because
they wronged us a lot of people they
they have a sort of attitude of well as
soon as you affect me I get to do
whatever I want to do to you or they may
in fact even think that's what I should
do in order to show myself as being
strong so nobody will will take
advantage of me and there and then there
could be some situations where that that
actually does make sense but Cicero is
saying look that doesn't make sense in
general we have to follow these duties
and those duties he says impose limits
the the latin term here that's in the
text is modo which means to a certain
degree right only so far only only this
much you can't say well you cut me off
in traffic so I get to you know cut you
off in traffic in such a way as to give
you the finger and maybe run you off the
road
that's very unproportional you know even
though it seems to be just the same sort
of thing it's not actually the same
thing or if you insult me then I get to
insult you as much as I like saying
whatever I want about you that is the
sign of somebody who's irrational
according to Cicero so we have limits
and what are those limits
he gives us some guidance about that in
Chapter 11 and in chapter 25 so let's
look at the first one which is that he
says that it's sufficient that the
aggressor the person who's doing the
wrong thing ought to be should be
brought to repent of their wrongdoing to
feel some sort of shame or feeling bad
or regret even if they just don't like
being punished
that's that's perhaps enough so it's
enough to make them say oh I shouldn't
have done that it may in fact be enough
just to bring it to their attention say
hey you hurt me over here and a good
person will actually feel bad because of
that so what is the point behind this
it's what we call deterrence there is a
number of different theories of
punishment and one of them is that
punishment should be carried out in
order to deter others and the person
who's being punished from engaging in
wrongdoing so you don't just punish for
the sake of punishment or because it
makes you feel good or you know other
sorts of reasons it's to send a message
to teach a lesson and that lesson is
don't do this kind of thing because when
you do we give you a fine or we you know
impose some sort of corporal penalty or
we do something else to you we shame you
publicly we do something you know we
take away your job or you know any any
of those sorts of things but it needs to
be enough to well take away freedoms and
what we do in our society right we send
people to jail or prison enough to deter
the wrongdoer and since real thanks to
deter others so perhaps in some cases
you would administer a a severe
punishment because you need to send a
message at that point in time that
listen this is not going to be allowed
we might think of you know cases where
law and order has broken down and you
need to impose something very quickly
but those are extraordinary cases those
are not the norm generally in order to
deter the person and others you don't
have to go too far with the punishment
and you can actually ask them hey is
this enough to keep you from doing it
and if they say no I'm still gonna do it
well then maybe you punish them some
more but if they if they you know you
think that they're being honest and they
say yeah I've learned my lesson
don't go on and punish them more and and
we might apply this not only to like
civil you know penalties within society
but we might think about public opinion
we might think about personal
relationships
and you know when we impose say the
silent treatment on somebody we're
punishing them and we could say well how
far should we impose it well until
they've learned their lesson and they're
gonna knock off doing whatever it is
that they were doing that was wrong so
this is one important aspect this
deterrence what else does he tell us
well we hear we have to jump ahead to
chapter 25 he says we need to take care
that punishment
you know Penant the penalty that we're
imposing the poana is proportioned to
the wrongdoing the culpa what it is that
the person has has done it has to be
proportionate to it or he says we need
to make sure that the penalty is not
greater than what it is that the
wrongdoing requires why not well because
he says the the aristotelian is the
Peripatetic s-- have got it right
punishment is really finding the right
middle ground the means what would
actually equalizes things what sets them
right and if we go beyond that we're not
doing justice we're not restoring
justice we're actually creating
injustice so if our desire for
retribution or vengeance draw going too
far we are making a fundamental mistake
and in place of creating justice or
re-enacting justice we create more
injustice which may provoke the the
person involved rightly so does saying
well it's all going to be injustice that
might undo the deterrence part we also
want to think about fairness and so
Cicero here talks about consistency if
we're going to punish one person for an
offense
we need to punish other people for that
same offense and if we're not going to
punish these other people then we
probably shouldn't
this person over here we shouldn't
single them out we might think as a
contemporary application of this about
the way in which laws are enforced and
then imposed by the judiciary so we're
talking about the executive and the
judiciary within cities and how
sometimes minority groups get policed a
lot harder than do the majority or you
know two people different races go
before the same judge same offense give
very different sentences that's a
problem that's injustice for where
Cicero stood so he he tells us here that
[Music]
yeah we shouldn't we should make sure
that some shall not be chastised for the
same fault for which others are not even
called to account we need to make a
decision we need to be consistent across
the board if we're going to punish for
this crime or if we're going to treat
people this way for doing this sort of
thing whether it be an insult and injury
you know whatever sort of other
wrongdoing what we're talking about here
we have to be consistent we can't give
people passes because when we do we're
not treating people fairly the other
thing that he says here that I think is
very very important to understand not
just from a stoic perspective but also
from Cicero's own perspective is that we
have to avoid a particular passion or
emotion and that emotion is the one
particularly associated with at least
retribution vengeance we might even say
punishment and that is anger in Latin
Eater a-- when we're talking about
somebody having ire or being a rascal
that's that's the emotion that we're
talking about and he says listen if you
are punishing while you're angry it's
going to be very difficult to follow any
of these guidelines because anger tends
to make you want to go further so you
may
pose you know too much for for the crime
or you may punish one person and not
punish the other person depending on how
you feel or you may forget about the
idea that you're just trying to deter
the person you're not trying to destroy
them or make them suffer even more you
don't want it to turn into cruelty so he
says that if anyone proceeds in a
passion to inflict punishment he's never
going to observe the mean condition that
the Peripatetic stalk about he says the
Aristotelian czar peripatetic also gets
something wrong they think that anger
can sometimes be good
cicero says in reality anger is in every
circumstance to be eradicated and those
who administer the government should be
like the laws which are led to inflict
punishment not by wrath but by justice
not because they have a personal stake
in it and feel like they've been
violated but rather because it's the
reasonable and right thing to do
Cicero thinks that we do have to punish
and that it does make sense to do this
but we shouldn't be doing this motivated
by the emotion of anger so these are
guidelines that that tell us how we live
out this this fact of having duties
moral duties obligations towards those
who wronged us it doesn't place them
beyond the pale allow us to do whatever
we want to do to them if we want to be
good people we have to actually follow
these guidelines
you